guardate questo sorriso vero bene grazie
sono contentissimo non potete capire
benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
questo video è molto importante per me
perché finalmente siamo arrivati ad
essere una grandissima famiglia composta
da un milione di persone
innanzitutto devo ringraziare tantissimo
tutti voi ognuno di voi per avermi
permesso di arrivare a questo grande
traguardo e soltanto grazie a voi se io
continuo da anni a apportare dei
contenuti sul mio canale perché so che
ci siete voi dall'altra parte che gli
apprezzate e che vi seguite sempre con
tanto tanto amore e tanto affetto quindi
per me questa è la cosa più importante e
cioè che se ho raggiunto questo
traguardo è perché secondo voi me lo
merito questa è la cosa veramente più
importante per me grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie grazie grazie ha detto
questo partiamo subito subito con il
video ho pensato finalmente di fare un
video che mi chiedete da tantissimo
tempo nel quale rispondo alle vostre
domande in merito al mio percorso sui
social quindi come ho iniziato quali
erano le mie paure come sempre nelle
storie instagram bio appunto messo la
boxe con le domande e voi mi avete
mandato tantissime domande e io
ovviamente ne ho selezionate alcune
diciamo secondo me quelle più
significative a proposito se non lo
avete ancora fatto mi raccomando
seguitemi sia su instagram che su tik
tok che ci sono tantissimi contenuti che
non posso qui ma possa appunto in questi
altri due soci
partiamo con la prima domanda quando hai
capito che fosse il momento di
percorrere questa strada come dico
sempre quando mi fanno questa domanda io
sono finita sui social assolutamente per
caso cercherò di far verrà più breve
possibile allora io ho sempre sognato di
fare la cantante di recitare insomma mi
piaceva e mi attraeva tutto quello che
riguardava il mondo dello spettacolo fin
da bambino ho fatto tantissimi provini
tantissimi casting e ho fatto i provini
per amici e xfactor
insomma cercava in tutti i modi di farmi
notare e di fare soprattutto quello che
mi piaceva fare cosa succede succede che
ai provini mi hanno mai preso quindi è
arrivato un momento della mia vita in
cui ero totalmente in down avevo quindi
perso totalmente le speranze non ci
credevo più non è stato un bel periodo
che cosa succede succede che
conoscevo un ragazzo della mia città che
faceva da video comici su facebook e
quindi un giorno aveva bisogno di una
ragazza che recitasse in un suo video e
mi ha chiamato e io da subito trovato
insomma affascinante quelle quel mondo
perché appunto mi è sempre piaciuto
recitare far divertire la gente è sempre
stata l'amica che faceva ridere il
gruppo e quindi mi sono trovato subito a
mio agio
quindi ho iniziato a pensare che anche
io avrei potuto fare una cosa di questo
tipo obbligare dei video in cui recitavo
cantavo insomma utilizzare il web come
vetrina ma attenzione non è stato
automatico perché avevo la paura
allucinante di espormi sui social quando
è qualcosa che chi bazzica per la testa
va allo stesso tempo dice sì ok però mai
quindi avevo da una parte l'angioletto
che mi diceva ma si dai boot di provaci
la tua occasione dall altro dialetto
come diceva ma va sai quanta gente ti
massacra la di insulti
sai quanto andrà in down se tuoi video
non piace eccetera eccetera o tipo in
mezzo alla fine cosa successe successo
semplicemente che quando è una passione
credo ci vuoi provare sempre fino alla
fine e quindi visto che avevo avuto
tante delusioni in questo ambito
nessuno aveva creduto in me ho pensato
io ci provo
mal che vada capirò che neanche questa è
la mia strada e mi metterò l'anima in
pace
proprio la vela vedevo dentro di me
proprio come l'ultima spiaggia e poi
seconda domanda un'altra domanda che mi
fate sempre
ti sei mai preoccupata del parere
negativo degli altri quando ho iniziato
a fare video avevo una paura
incredibile di qualsiasi commento
negativo degli haters ti di tutto e che
appunto era un mondo nuovo per me e mi
stavo esponendo tanto come l'avevo mai
fatto in vita via e quindi era anche
normale che io avessi questa questa
paura ovviamente con il tempo vedendo
che la maggior parte della gente mi
apprezzava e mi faceva dei dei
complimenti i pochi grazie a dio
commenti negativi tuoi ricevute in
questi anni mi sono fatto andare bene
perchè alla fine non puoi piacere a
tutti ognuno di noi è libero di
esprimere un parere
in positivo o negativo sempre nei limiti
e cercando di rispettare altra persona
senza insultare senza dire cose brutte
non molto fortunata perché ad oggi ho
ricevuto pochi messaggi e commenti
negativi quindi mi ritengo veramente
fortunata perché hai deciso di fare la
youtuber allora come ho detto prima io
non l'ho deciso nel senso ci sono finita
per caso in questo mondo e ovviamente
vedendo che i miei video piacevano e la
gente mi apprezzava per per i miei
contenuti per la mia voce insomma ho
capito che avrei potuto continuare
facendomi conoscere ancora di più sui
social per poi ovviamente provare a fare
quello che ho sempre voluto fare cioè
cantare e recitare cosa hai provato
quando hai pubblicato il primo video su
youtube
io ho iniziato a pubblicare i video su
facebook e forse solo un anno due anni
dopo ha iniziato pubblicarli anche su
youtube
quindi per me il primo video che ho
caricato è stato su facebook e ricordo
che avevo paura livelli estremi e che lo
stesso neo per oro molto elettrizzata
perché appunto volevo volevo sapere che
cosa ne pensava la gente volevo mettermi
alla prova
da qui ci colleghiamo a questa domanda
qual è stato il primo video che è
pubblicato ti adoro vi sarà ultimi
chiamo katia innanzi tutto ciò cambia il
primo video che ho pubblicato è il video
una ragazza 23 cantante visto che ho
sempre fatto l'imitazione dei cantanti e
il primo video che mi è venuto in mente
di girare è stato appunto questo quindi
io che imitavo 23 cantanti diverse è un
video cappella quindi senza base sotto e
si sente semplicemente la mia voce e
niente lo riguardo è partito un sacco di
difetti
insomma per quanto riguarda il canto
però penso sia normale però allo stesso
tempo vi fa e fa tenerezza perché si
vede che ero proprio ragazzina come
gradualmente ai aumentato i follower
beh non c'è un come nel senso che ho
continuato semplicemente a passare nei
video e quindi sono cresciuta
innanzitutto su facebook in breve tempo
sono arrivata a un milione di mi piace e
che adesso che non lo usa quasi più
nessuno però ai tempi anche gli era
stato un traguardo enorme
poi mi sono spostata su youtube
parallelamente ho aperto instagram di
poi appena arrivato music ari per chi
non lo sapesse il nome che aveva prima
tik tok ho subito aperto anche il mio
profilo su music anni ha iniziato a
tantissimi video anche lì e anche lì da
poco credo 12 mesi sono arrivata a un
milione sono già un milione 1 quindi
sono molto contenta insomma di essere
presente su tutti i social su ogni
social posto contenuti diversi e la cosa
bella è che in questo modo riesco a
raggruppare tantissimi pubblici diversi
e riesco arrivare un po a tutti ecco
bella domanda
il tuo video preferito ce ne sono tanti
ma è il video che a distanza di anni
ogni volta che lo riguardo vi rende
super orgogliosa di quello insomma che
ho fatto è il monologo contro la
violenza sulle donne
in questi giorni ha ricevuto un sacco di
bei per il milione e tantissimi mi hanno
conosciuto grazie a quel video che cosa
mi piace di quei video beh innanzitutto
mi piace il fatto di essere arrivata
attraverso quelle parole attraverso quel
monologo sono contentissima di aver
trasmesso un messaggio molto importante
e soprattutto sono super orgogliosa e
fiera di questo video perché è il video
più proiettato nelle scuole e questa è
una delle cose più belle perché sono
riuscita a far arrivare questo messaggio
che è molto importante a toccare un tema
sociale così delicato ea raggiungere
tantissimi ragazzini è importante per
chi come come me ha un canale riesce
arrivare a tante persone
riuscire anche a sensibilizzare a
trasmettere dei messaggi sociali
importanti e io sono contentissima di
questo mio video veramente tanto nel tuo
percorso da you tube rai trovato degli
ostacoli che supera d'oro che adora
anch'io
non pensate che nel mondo delle web star
nel mondo dello spettacolo in tutti
questi mondi scintillanti che immaginate
non ci siano brutte persone non ci siano
ostacoli non ci siano persone che
cercano di schiacciarti e di sfruttarti
grazie a dio sono stata fortunata perché
ho trovato tante persone di kakà ma
anche alcune per stelle persone che mi
hanno aiutato insomma a individuare la
gente di kakà e ad eliminarla dalla mia
vita e superare gli ostacoli ci rende
più forti e non
ormai scoraggiarci e dobbiamo sempre
avere avanti ad essa alta farci così per
raggiungere a realizzare i nostri sogni
ricordatevelo sempre sentivi già in
precedenza che saresti arrivata questo
traguardo
ragazzi ma io quando pubblicato iniziato
a pubblicare video fa vuol dire non so
neanche cosa avrei fatto che giornata
era proprio una roba che pensavo non mi
avrebbe portato nessuna parte
avevo assolutamente nessun tipo di
aspettativa e mai mi sarei aspettata di
arrivare ad avere quasi 4 milioni di
follower totali mai hai mai paura di
fare dire qualcosa per non dare un buon
esempio visto target dei follower
assolutamente sì come potete notare io
non dico mai parolacce cerco sempre di
utilizzare un linguaggio pulito
proprio per questo motivo perché so che
seguono anche ragazzi più piccoli cerco
sempre di fare attenzione per quanto
riguarda questo questo tema con amo
infatti i colleghi che dicono parolacce
o peggio ancora perché comunque io
immagino un giorno quando sarò quando
sarò un genitore non avrei piacere che
mio figlio vedesse dei video magari
vedesse come degli idoli dei ragazzi che
non fanno altro che dire cose brutte e
volgari volevi fare la cantante
all'inizio come ti è venuta l'idea di
cambiare genere allora io tuttora voglio
fare la cantante come sapete ho
pubblicato la scorsa estate il mio primo
singolo e sto lavorando per farne uscire
altri quindi questo continua a essere un
mio grande sogno non l'ho mai
abbandonato perché come sapete ho
pubblicato in questi anni anche molte
cover molti video in cui cantò quindi ho
sempre cercato di trasmettervi
quest'altra mia passione
sicuramente per farmi conoscere a più
gente possibile i video comici mi hanno
aiutato tanto perché appunto per
tantissime persone si riescono a
riconoscere in questi video ma a cantare
sempre stata la mia passione e non lo
abbandonerò mai ho semplicemente cercato
di postare contenuti che mi
rispecchiassero quindi contenuti comici
il cui canto video in cui recito il mio
canale un po il mio mondo quindi ho
cercato di riversare tutto quello che
che io sono non hai mai avuto paura di
finire nel dimenticatoio o di fallire o
del pensiero degli altri allora finire
nel dimenticatoio
sì spesso ci ho pensato perché non è
detto che se i tuoi video piacciono per
12 anni e poi continuino a interessare
il tuo pubblico
la mia fortuna tra virgolette è che io
ho iniziato a fare video su youtube
non perché volessi diventare una youtube
ma perché volevo mostrare le mie le mie
passioni e quindi l'ho usata un po come
una vetrina come un palco dove mi
esibivo e quindi se fini si è
dimenticato reeves piacerebbe tantissimo
ma continuerà comunque a coltivare le
mie passioni e cioè il canto e la
recitazione detto questo non mi fate
fine il diventi come sei riuscita
realizzare questo tuo sogno è difficile
essere una youtubers e sì perché
risponde solo la seconda domanda perché
alla prima già praticamente risposto non
vorrei dilungarmi troppo
non mi piace tanto il fatto che alcune
persone pensino che chi crea contenuti
chi fossero i contenuti su youtube non
faccia nulla non ci sia del lavoro
dietro perché vi assicuro che non è così
mi piacerebbe tanto le cose così ma non
è così e sicuro che c'è tanto lavoro
notti in bianco montare i video le idee
le idee con la cosa principale è quella
cioè bisogna avere delle idee e
creatività perché io da 44 anni che
posto video e nessuno mi ha mai scritto
un video sono sempre state mie idee non
è facile avere sempre nuove idee ogni
settimana che la regola numero uno qui
su youtube e la costanza nel pubblicare
video il fatto che i tuoi contenuti
siano interessanti abbiano appeal
piacciano le persone allo stesso tempo
deve avere anche idee originali se no
faremo tutti gli stessi video quindi non
è assolutamente facile anche solo il
partorire l'idea del video figuratevi il
lavoro che c'è dietro quindi girare il
video l'editing del video chi mi segue
su instagram avrà visto che faccio anche
le 4 e le 5 del mattino per montare i
video non amo giudicare i lavori i
lavori degli altri non mi piace quando
giudicano il mio io so solo che ci metto
tutta me stessa e spero che erano
trovate lì voi l'abbiamo notato lo so
che tanti vivo era notato perché me lo
scrivono non mi piace tanto il
pregiudizio che c'è nei confronti degli
youtuber perché se siete qua a guardarci
e perché forse qualcosa a livello
facciamo è perché c'è anche tanto lavoro
dietro quindi la risposta alla domanda è
difficile è facile che vale difficile
strada youtube
niente difficile se ci metti passione ma
questo non toglie che ci sia tanto
lavoro dietro carina anche a questa
domanda i social hanno centrato sei
stato tu a scegliere i social
a questo punto i soci hanno scelto me
perché se ho avuto successo dal primo
video ci credo molto nel destino è visto
che appunto come detto era un periodo
dove ero veramente su questa cosa mi ha
fatto rialzare e quindi io credo che
qualcuno ci aveva messo lo zampino non
so chi ma qualcuno mi hanno dato una
mano quindi assunto forse i social hanno
scelto me forse doveva andare qual è
stato il momento in cui ti sei reso
conto di essere molto apprezzata
iniziamo col dire che milioni di più i
live sotto i video contano ma secondo me
essere apprezzati è un'altra cosa io
guardando un video che mi fa ridere
metto laiche detto commento però da lì
apprezzare e stimare e vedere una
sorella come un'amica la persona che
recita in quel video c'è differenza
quindi io ho capito mi sono resa conto
di essere apprezzata quando leggevo i
vostri messaggi in cui mi dicevate
quello che rappresentavo per voi che non
era soltanto a tu per ridere la ragazza
dei video era tu mi hai aiutato in
questo momento difficoltà tu ci sei
stata quando è successa questa cosa è la
mia vita i tuoi video mi hanno dato la
forza di reagire e quello essere
apprezzato i like e i numeri sotto i
video mi rendono molto felice perché
vuol dire che riguardano tante persone
però non riguardano me lo so come non so
se avete capito cioè non riguarda la mia
sfera proprio in chi mai la mia persona
guardano lo che faccio tua madre ti ha
sostenuta in questo percorso ragazzi ma
di cosa stiamo parlando cioè mia madre e
chi può la mia fan numero uno cioè
appena esce un video scritto il suo like
mi manda l'audio dove ride segnano il
fai troppo di rete proprio simpatica poi
ovviamente gamma visto tutto il 3
youtube e quindi tutto il periodo in cui
voce classico comunque tornava a casa
piangendo da e quindi vedere insomma la
propria figlia che è successo che viene
apprezzata tante persone penso che non
ci sia niente di più bello per una mamma
no a questo anche carina eri già una
youtuber quando ti sei fidanzata allora
quanto
ami consalvo avevo solo facebook credo
si era già conosciuta su sul web
non mi ricordo stato già aperto entra da
pubblicare su youtube è infatti una
delle nostre prime uscite lui mi diceva
che apprezzava molto i video che si
vedeva che c'era molto molto talento e
passione in quello che facevo dice vabbè
se tattica per provarci e invece credo
spero che lo pensi
un'ultima domanda ti sei sentita
cambiata quando dopo aver intrapreso
questo percorso sinceramente mi sento
sempre la stessa ragazzina l'unica cosa
che magari ovviamente adesso sono un po
più sicura di me e questo anche grazie a
voi perché senza di voi e senza il
vostro appoggio non credo che sarei qui
a parlarvi ma anche grazie tutte le cose
che mi avete scritto in questi anni
ovviamente mi avete dato una forza
immensa e quindi sicuramente sono più
consapevole di quello che sono di quello
che voglio e delle mie credo
potenzialità ma allo stesso tempo sotto
tanti aspetti sono sempre la stessa
casinista la testa tra le nuvole
giocherellona cioè non sono cresciuto
sotto tanti lati e sono richieste
proprio una ragazzina ma questo è il
bello di me che sono così un po
spensierata e che cerco sempre di vedere
le cose in maniera positiva per quanto
sia possibile spero tantissimo che
questo video vi sia piaciuto ridico già
che non sarà l'unico video per lo
speciale del milione ce ne saranno altri
mi raccomando
siamo arrivati al milione arriviamo ai 2
milioni adesso quindi se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale
cliccate sulla campanella vicino a tassa
d'iscrizione per ricevere una notifica
tutte le volte che pubblico
fatemi sapere nei commenti cosa ne
pensate insomma di queste domande di
quello che ho detto e delle vostre
riflessioni quello che volete io sono
qua e leggerò tutto tutto tutto
adoro